ouais on va aller poursuivre maintenant
avec notre ami badass à bienne qui est
toujours la patrouille et le web pour
nous et bador vous allez nous montrer ce
qui se comprend plus en avant après ce
qui nous va nous donner une idée pleine
et entière de l'étendue des dommages
c'est ça je vais vous montrer je vais
vous le décrire aussi si ça c'est une
photo de tourisme mégantic
regardez c'est une photo de la rue
frontenac je vais m'écarter ici on peut
voir plusieurs commerces 1 2 3 4 5 5 3 4
bâtiments environ un commerce notamment
à commerce d'un magasin dollars ici donc
une rue achalandée des commerces et
regarder ça c'est la photo qu'on a eues
aujourd'hui sa fin c'est une photo du
service de protection des incendies de
la ville de québec et les pompiers de
québec là bas et il ne reste plus rien
le magasin 1 $ / / à l'étagé bien il
reste juste les structures en acier
vous pouvez vous imaginer ça vous donne
une idée de l'ampleur de la débâcle en
pleurs d'explosions et si une autre
photo le restaurant la chapelle qui se
trouvent aussi sur la rue franklin
graham est un bâtiment patrimonial de
trois étages est là pour vous montrer la
pré écoute et il reste juste les façades
qui tiennent difficilement debout
le reste a été pratiquement rayé de la
carte de cet édifice en brique et vous
remercie infiniment bador parce
qu'effectivement ces images résument à
elles seules à quel point ben il reste
pas grand chose